why are we afraid of change when it's
the thing that we actually sometimes
fantasize about it's as soon as we get
into that unknown
at least we know the parts we don't like
about it at least there's a certain
certain comfort and being able to
anticipate and being able to have that
expectation that's often met because
we're in a place that we know when a
change occurs we have expectations and
we have no idea if it's going to get met
we don't know what's about to happen and
so I think it's that darkness that
unknown that really is what inspires
that fear and honestly I'm grateful for
it because in fear is energy and I think
that if we can allow that fear to then
guide us inform us it's it's all the
better right so I think that it's a
natural inheritance of our species and I
think it's there for a reason and I
think we need to remain in tune to use
it to move us to move us forward